welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Chloe Starr assistant professor of
Asian Christianity and theology at Yale
University she has published on Chinese
literature and Chinese theology and her
recent works include red light novels of
the late Ching a co edited volume the
quest for gentility in China and an
edited volume reading Christian
scriptures in China today we talk with
her about her forthcoming book Chinese
intellectual Christianity welcome
professor star thank you let's begin
with an overview of your book tell us
about it so the book Chinese
intellectual Christianity traces the
currents the major currents of Chinese
theology and some of the main figures
who've been writing Chinese theology
starting in the late Imperial period in
the Jesuit era when the Jesuits were
there and the theologians were Chinese
literati moving through the late Qing to
the Republican era and then on through
the 20th century into the beginning of
the 21st century okay and what led you
to write the book um several things
first of all it's hugely interesting
especially Republican era theology it's
one of my favorite periods of theology
when there's a huge flourishing of
thinking about what it means to have a
Chinese theology that isn't tied too
much to Western thought and thinking but
is really you know engaged with Chinese
society and Chinese ways of thinking and
writing um one of the reasons I wanted
to write this book was for an
english-speaking audience there's very
little out there that's Chinese theology
in English there's very little good
academic work and so when I teach
courses I ascribe readings another
reason I wanted to write the book was
for Chinese speaking audience there's
been a lot of work over the last decade
or so revising the history we have of
Chinese Christianity was a whole period
from around the 1930s to the 1980s or so
when Christianity was wiped out of the
record whether it's the history Doria
graphical record or whether it's the
Chinese literature
record and what thinkers are doing now
is rien scribing Christianity that was
always there into the record so people
are working on the Chinese Christian
colleges from the nineteen ten a lot of
historians are opening up new archives
and rethinking Christianity in that
period in a more positive sense than was
possible during the Communist era okay
so that's why it was wiped out because
it was during the time of communism in
China yeah there's one more reason which
is really important to why I wanted to
write the book and that's because the
Chinese Church is essentially being
split since the 1950s into the house
Church the underground Church and the
state church and the house church people
who a lot of whom spent decades in
prison for their stance on Christianity
and the government still regard the
mainstream the state church in the
Protestant side the three-self principal
movement church as communist Stooges or
people who capitulated and worked with
the communist government not not somehow
Christian so one of the things I want to
do and I think in a way it's almost
easier as an outsider is to go back to
the beginning of some of the debates in
the 1950s and look at the figures
involved so ding guangtian on the state
church side somebody like warming down
on the house church side and actually
see revisit those arguments and and see
if there's a way of reconciling their
theological views or reconciling their
relation to the government from our
present position to sort of rethink this
huge split in the church ok so again the
time frame of your book starts when and
ends where it starts in the sixteenth
seventeenth century with some of the
Chinese thinkers so it's there's four
phases in the book and the the sort of
the model of the book is tied to the
flourishing periods of Chinese
Christianity so it's not tied to Mission
history it's not tied to secular history
it focuses in on the exciting
theological periods so the first one is
late Imperial when you have the three
pillars of the church in the Ming
Dynasty
who are rethinking and interacting with
their Jesuit priest friends and teachers
and beginning to think about writing
apologetics or Chinese Christian works
and the second phase is in the early
20th century in the Republican era 1920s
and 30s you had a lot of Chinese
students going abroad so we had people
studying at Columbia at Union
Theological Seminary in the US and then
going back to China and teaching so a
lot of the theologians in this period
were university teachers and lectures
and these are sort of some of the
intellectuals of my title but they're
also hugely socially engaged and so the
theology of this period is looking at
you know what can the church do for
China and that's true even in the later
period this is sort of it so the
theological stream I'm looking at is not
really so much the house church or the
independent Chinese churches but the
stream of theologians who were in the
sort of Chinese literati tradition
really deeply engaged with society and
with Chinese society and we're trying to
think theologically about what it means
to be Chinese huge questions in the
1920s were about identity who are we as
Chinese Christians because you've got
westernization and modernization going
on you've got a huge anti-christian
movement you've got a pro-science
movement so the theologians in the 1920s
are trying to write an apologetics so
you get a very rational theology very
few miracles in there but they're also
trying to create a social gospel how can
we bring the kingdom of heaven on earth
now in China in the 1920s and 30s how
popular was Christianity you know
throughout those time periods I mean
Christianity and perhaps I'm wrong in
this was basically brought to China by
missionaries is that correct
the Nestorian Church Church of the East
Syria speaking church have missionaries
monks in China in the seventh century
we've got documentary evidence from
around 65 ad okay but that sort of phase
of Christianity died out and are the
prohibitions on Christianity in the
ninth century in the late tang and then
you have the Franciscans and then you
have the Jesuits and then you have the
Protestant mission era the heyday in the
sort of 19th century of sending huge
numbers of missionaries to China
percentage-wise has never been so many
Christians in China I mean even now
estimates between 60 and 100 million
Chinese Christians okay so tell me about
how you're doing your
research and I'm wondering about like
you know language as well how that fits
into what you're doing so almost all of
the materials were all materials I'm
using almost all of the materials I'm
using are in Chinese so they're either
in classical Chinese from the early
period or they're in modern Chinese from
the 20th century and one of the things
I'm trying to do in the book is is
create a narrative that moves through
not many texts have actually integrated
classical Chinese writings of a
theological nature with modern ones and
integrated Protestant and Catholic works
so that's one of the things I'm trying
to do but by looking at text of
individual authors so each section of
the volume has a historical a background
chapter and then it'll have two or three
chapters going into detail looking at
the text of individual theologians so I
spend a lot of time photocopying in Hong
Kong in a couple of years ago in the
libraries and I've also talked to
various Roman Catholic theologians and
friends about who is the most
interesting 20th century Roman Catholic
theologian and then they gave me all
these names of Taiwanese and I said no i
need mainland people I'm interested in
mainland Chinese thinking so and was
there a general opinion about who that
was or it's difficult on the Roman
Catholic side because there hasn't been
so much original thinking it's been
monly trammeled by Vatican currents of
thought on the Protestant side you have
a lot more because the the movement
towards a Chinese Chinese church towards
independence and autonomy happened in
the 1910s and 20s at the same time as
huge numbers of independent churches
were growing up and also with these
returnees theologians coming back from
the u.s. newly trained up newly excited
with this of new critical thinking
writing sort of innovative Chinese
theology okay and you know during the
process of your research did you come
across anything that particularly
surprised you that you weren't expecting
perhaps one of the things that's been
most fun I did literature in my early
degrees in Chinese is the way that some
of the Chinese theological writings are
really using Chinese literary forms to
say new things about Christianity so I
have a chapter on Dad's a ton who's a
theologian who was writing in the 1920s
and 30s and he likes a bi
a life of Jesus now there are many lives
of Jesus in by Western writers at that
time in his one he uses Chinese poems
from the classical corpus as chapter
titles for example and he uses so many
images from you know four character
phrases and all these sort of Chinese
images and he reads the text in a
Chinese way and then he reads the life
of cheezer's as a Chinese literati Award
so for example one of the things he's
doing he reads the landscape of Nazareth
and Judea as if he were a sort of
Chinese poet standing there reading this
layered landscape with all the memories
built into it so we get we get a sort of
Chinese take on the gospel in bad and
another of the writers I'm looking at at
the moment in the same period as
shuzhong he's a Roman Catholic writer
and he wrote these diary entries it's
called the BG form in Chinese and it's
basically jottings it's a bit like a
blog or even some of it's like a retweet
so I I see this thing in a newspaper and
I'm telling you about it and he he
published these in a church magazine
over three years and then he collected
them into this book but the diary form
is a very Chinese form of writing so the
things he says in that and the sort of
theological thoughts he has are a deeply
Chinese and are not really for a Western
readership because they seem they seem
very unsystematic none of the
theologians I'm writing actually write
systematic theology in western terms so
it's very tied to Chinese literary forms
and Chinese ways of thinking and I think
that's something that hasn't been
explored so much before interesting and
what what are some of the conclusions
that you reach in the book one of the
sort of most interesting things about
twentieth-century and Chinese theology
is how closely the church and the state
are tied and how closely mainstream
theologians are working with and
thinking through some of the Communist
requirements on the state but but even
even in the nationalist area at the 20s
and 30s
how what Christianity can do for China
is one of the main currents of thought
and you see that again in the final
Christian theology of the 1990s and
2000's how can we leverage this
Christian theology to have some
use in the public sphere to have some
sort of ethical effect in China that's
one of the questions a lot of the
academic theologians are thinking about
at the moment so what are some of the
examples of things that Christianity can
do for China that you've read in your
research so at one level of governments
are very positive about some aspects of
Protestantism at the moment in the
spiritual vacuum and void in the post
cultural revolution era and the
generation that's grown up without a
value set so some of the Christian
academic theologians are thinking about
okay how can Christian theological
ethics be brought into national life and
some of the public intellectuals are
wanting to bring Christianity into
public discourse and within the academic
sphere to use the methodology of
theology as a counterpoint to some of
the sort of Marxian humanistic
methodologies okay well when can we look
for to your book coming out I'm hoping
they'll be out in 2015 okay very good
fascinating thank you for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
work thank you so much thank you for
more information about Professor star
and her research please visit our
website at Yale edu / Macmillan report
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale